citizens of the reject nation we are here today to
watch cobra kai season five episode five extreme
measures john how's it going it's going great
andrew it is also going great andrew gossey's
shirts forgot to mention in the last episode thank
you andrew thank you you're welcome you're welcome
my pleasure guys i'm grateful anyway we are
going to watch this uh leave a like that would
be very much appreciated subscribe click that
notification bell to get notified when a reaction
for the next episode is up here on the channel
and as always following threats and watch long
as we sync up with your own copy available
at our patreon page for super sexy rejects
the team of prepper thank you for helping
us edit down these highlights let's do this
yeah i was just thinking about stingray my man
that was a new place you settling in oh yeah yeah
yes sensei thank you god i'm a new place i want
my loyal soldier living in style it's the least
i could do in light of your sacrifice
and i tend to do more than the least
oh holy [__] was it worth it but it
should be a stingray check the trunk
oh nice tell you what i'm gonna get you guys
a basket of bread sticks fresh out of the oven
i'll come right back down and all right guys
i do have good breadsticks breadsticks aren't
gonna fix this spoken like a man who's never had
the garden's breadsticks one bite you forget why
you were ever mad each other in the first place
yeah i'm never gonna forget that neither am i
at least have some bread sticks oh
garden got a good promotion there
they paid for that whole scene in
fact i'm gonna go there after this
oh you know seriously he's got some facial hair
yeah i don't think we've ever seen him without
facial hair and his hair is not perfectly combed
with mirror no envelope for all we know this is
just silver sending us out on a wild goose chase
so he could screw up my life even worse could be
would be stingray you sure don't come to dinner
no you and your cousin should catch up okie dokie
oh is that robin lively from karate kid part
three yes definitely it is and yes that's
why you're here jessica andrews oh what's all of
this i don't worry about it i want a beer cactus
you literally just said he wasn't here yeah i
lied again not my fault you fell for it twice
found a bunch of strategies for building trust and
teamwork through cooperative exercises the
least lame one is called an escape room
i reverse the door knobs it's
a lot from the inside and
how are they gonna get out now i mean you
two have your thing whatever but you keep
forcing this all you're gonna do is get his
ass kicked oh ready when you are runner-up
and the time in the place oh my god you guys
i am billy the kid and i have a video for you
just fight it out guys yeah you'll feel better
chris put this guy in a coma and now he's
driving around on a cobra kai billboard on wheels
put him in a coma beat him up for
real in the wreckage of my life
there's a nice sony uh tie in there with a
ps4 sensei silver is an honorable man and he
felt terrible for whatever sensei silver came
after my family that's the kind of man he is
well if that is true then you must have done
something to deserve it all right you're gonna
give me a goddamn straight answer no no not
the ps4 my playstations who gives a [__]
about your playstation danielson enough
you are not yourself you're a bully daniel
it's always been a hothead now terry's gonna have
to get him a ps5 this guy's never gonna help us
but i know someone who can hillary swing
i knew it hey chris sakes amanda steiner
hey lizzie ann remember she was the one that beat
up that car with the baseball bat ah nickname that
we gave you after that god it was so good but
god i wish i could remember you know but it's so
long ago you know we're gonna catch up it was good
talk fight them you have to open it from out there
oh my god oh i washed my hands of the cobra
kai thing when we lost a tournament what
you you started the whole cobra kai thing if
you hadn't brought it back none of this would be
happening you opened pandora's box not me listen
i don't know who pandora is or what's in her box
you don't want to know what happened to the
strike first badass huh do i need to kick his
ass to wake him up or it was just one tournament
loss all it took to turn you into oh my god
what are you doing uh raving like a lunatic
eureka booze and now you're gonna fight me
cause i don't wanna get pulled back into this
rivalry with silver what's going on with you man
nice i like that if you think i'm off
the rails way off she's got the pierce
jenga beer she's at her mother's
in ohio she took the kids with her
ah that makes sense jessica andrews ohio
yeah karate kid three we know easter eggs
mess you up andrew terry silver he
was hosting a charity funk sorry
terry silver is back i understood that reference
first he pretended to be his friend
then his mentor hey come on guys
while his goons wrecked his bonsai
shop beat him up they assaulted me
but he got past it back then so he can get past it
now right yeah except he didn't really get past it
then did he goddamn robbie moved in for a bit now
him and miguel are at each other's throats again
this is my dumb idea to try to get him
to iron it out but it crashed and burned
so much for goggles advice on conflict
resolution goggles google you know maybe
that's how we should have done it all those
years ago if we hadn't had to stop at three
points we might have gotten this all out of our
systems exactly three points is all you had in you
there he is all right on that
note should he be driving
should uh do ride show with johnny can
you give me a lift home babe ruthless
break that beer bottle on her head thanks for
the trip down memory lane oh oh i'm sorry does
miss coastal elite not like to be reminded of
where she came from blow it out your ass rooney
why don't you make me andrews
stay in your lane steiner this is a bar not a
yoga class so unless you've got a bat hiding
behind that bony butt of yours i don't
need a bat for you [__] stamp oh [__]
jesus christ do it same
it's not worth losing my
family over i have failed you
nah man it's not you defending honor of miyagido
never a waste of time no is helping friend
oh here it is fight fight
i love how those are the only
two that came out oh okay yeah
i was like you two stay put are you kidding
me down how many times go ahead yeah yeah
at least be men about it and put
your fist where your mouths are
we want us to do what fight it out don't even
get a stretch warm-up what here now that's a
time this is a place i'm sure carmen's cool with
this they both end up hospitalized good parenting
is that all you got
thought you guys were sworn enemies
nice hell yeah oh it's getting real
uh-oh nobody makes me bleed my own blood
oh my god his back
oh sheeps
it's not a bad fight at all
christ oh my god please stay off the second level
oh i'm so worried right now i like how johnny's
just sitting down there oh my god oh my god
get a mattress out dude
ah
yikes did we just become best friends yep
i mean i barely knew where we were i'd
take it back in a second if i could
i mean i was the cause of
the worst moment in your life
and if it's any consolation it was
the worst moment of my life too
is it over you guys good
oh thank god cause if you still hated
each other when the baby gets here
like you and my mom yeah we're
having a baby we're supposed to tell you
together so make sure you act surprised holy
[__] subversion of expectations
that's awesome
the sam whoo girl's got skills well it's in her
blood i guess so is uh protecting her loved ones
that one she gets from the both of you and the
larger point you're clearly trying to make it
daniel on the other hand has every reason to
hate terry silver after what he put him through
you're saying i should cut him some slack yeah
that's exactly what i'm saying what about johnny
diggins oh they got the breadsticks i
hope it's cool i'm having dinner here
it's very cool you're welcome anytime here robbie
oh this is so touching yeah that's so sweet these
guys are getting along now how did you manage that
and please don't tell me the bruises on their
faces mean that you beat them into submission
no of course not they beat
each other into submission
it was actually larussa's idea i didn't know
you and daniel were working together again
we weren't but i think we might need to hmm
i got your new playstation if it's not
a ps5 it's no good yep it sucks it's
remarkable how easy it was to disrupt your
marriage imagine how easy it's going to be
to wrap cobra kai keys around both your kids
yeah oh [__] it's not good that's it
larusso that's the kobrakai student i remember
use the pressure points oh
oh my god what the hell doing
a michael myers trick on him
you bit off more than you could chill and now that
the writing's on the wall you want to surrender
no no no we are way past the
time for white flags danny boy
oh nice work holy [__] tricks remind
me of bane and dark knight rises
where's chosen i want you alive
and well for what's about to happen
because the real pain is above to begin
to the pain damn god damn it
it's only getting worse talking to chris
therapy he's imprisoned nah she's pretty
sure she's visiting chris and i'm delivering
anonymous notes that can put people in danger
huh damn there must be another way
or at least somebody else out
there who wants to be in this fight
it was just [__] personal yeah goddamn
there is an endgame kid silver's
going down only he doesn't know it yet
i've taught all the prisoners karate
going down by recruiting hillary swing
dude greg is calling it it's gonna happen
cause yeah he'll get beat by girl and he'll
be super humility swink it up swank spank
let's go swank a tank swink attack all right
go go i know you want to speak uh well
couple the references obviously the
the uh easy ones are jessica andrews from karate
kid part three robin lively uh we did hear
part three i said part three uh we got uh
i don't think you said it several times
okay karate kid sorry guys sorry karate kid part
three jessica andrews uh we got uh they went to
ohio which is where we heard she was from in the
first film i kind of mentioned that already and
then also we heard them uh talking about climbing
uh which of course we remember in the fir in the
third film which uh her and daniel did a few times
and we saw the picture of her with her boyfriend
that she likes to climb uh in the mountains and
then also we saw obviously the reference that
they showed us with danny uh making his knuckles
get bloody which is also a reference of course to
karate kid part two and chris is trying to punch
miyagi and he gets the bloody knuckles as well
so yeah those are the references i got in regards
to this episode uh wow even though terry silver is
not a very big part of this episode he's more
towards the end again his influence on this
episode is is very much felt and i love that and
i love again just how much he's broken daniel up
until the uh not only physically but just mentally
and spiritually i mean we've never seen daniel
this low uh there's obviously a point in season
two at the end of season two and in season three
where the dealership's not doing well and amanda
was really upset with him in season two uh where
she was kind of like not talking to him because
he wasn't doing well balancing between the dojo
and between their marriage so she was
kind of giving him the cold shoulder but
this is a different level and it just shows again
the power of terry silver not only physically but
just again how he's just able to manipulate daniel
and even in an episode where he's only you know
shown at the end just how much he's broken daniel
it's just i thought it was a very interesting you
know uh way of showing like just seeing daniel
never seen him i mean again karate kid part three
we saw that he really suffered from a lot of you
know anxiety and anger and really just couldn't
control himself and just wanted to uh you know
had a lot of like i said a lot of anger problems
that he had in that film but it's just i thought
it was really interesting and ralph macchio got
to show off that acting range that he has and i
really thought it was fascinating watching daniel
struggle with that throughout this episode i mean
just seeing him with facial hair i was like wow
it's a different look for daniel and i appreciate
that and thought ralph macchio really carried this
episode and was great and i really loved too that
scene he had with johnny where it kind of flipped
itself where in seasons one through four or even
uh or one through three i would guess because
in season four johnny cleaned up his act but
usually johnny was the drunk one and daniel was
the sober one and you know would give him like
hey you should do this or do that so that's why
the writers and the creators of the show are so
brilliant how they're able to you know reverse
things and and do things differently but in a
very satisfying and emotionally paid-off way
that i really deeply appreciate and also too
i think johnny missed his call as a therapist
that was impressive what he did with robbie and
miguel and i even though the resolve was kind of
quick even though they did fight it out and i i
know that has been proven over time like hey just
just fight it up put some boxing gloves on just
fight it out you guys will uh you know let out
your stress and your and your hatred towards each
other you'll be friends afterwards i know that's a
somewhat of a proven technique uh with children
of all ages but um greg's like yeah that's what
we you guys do exactly i'll just let you
beat me to a pulp but i i actually did
i actually i actually even though the result
even though the resolve was very quickly done
i actually did buy that i mean we've been building
to kind of the redemption arc of these two like
maybe just not becoming best friends or per se but
at least just having a res mutual respect for one
each other when it comes to miguel and robbie and
i thought it was very well executed and done in a
very satisfying way to the point where i was like
you know what i buy this i'd buy that for a dollar
robocop reference and also too i did like that we
got a little bit of the backstory as well with uh
amanda seeing like oh that's how she met
daniel it was through to the love intro
or i guess not the love interest but the
female character from karate kid part three
i thought that was really well done and the well
told and uh also too uh one more reference we got
where they were talking about her beating the
bat on the car of the teacher we heard amanda
tell that to daniel in last season because where
she was trying to tell daniel why she's helping
out tori's because she suffered from a lot of
anger problems in high school she said that her
i believe it was her father or mother
i can't remember one of them was
going out with uh her history or uh teacher so
that we kind of got a little bit of the payoff
there and her name was baby uh babe ruthless
or something like that ruthless yeah so yeah
i like everything you said thank you that was
really well put thank you i appreciate your
insights and uh no would not have recognized her
right away the way you did robin lively yeah yes
so from karate kid part three part three that's
the one the third one make sure it's the right
part of three is that yeah i would
definitely whenever they played the music
as if it was a character that i should know
yeah and i was like i don't know what that
is you thought it was hilary swank oh he's
like hillary strength looks different than
ever and seen her in the movie her whole facial
structure has changed so you being here was really
helpful because as much as they did establish it
later on definitely wasn't an instant recognition
on my end she looks a little different a little
older a little older but it still looks good
yeah everybody in that in that uh you know
class aged well oh go ahead why don't you go
no no no no okay you go you go i'll find the thing
you guys did not talk about you're a bread stick
i could always take it out take it away uh yeah i
think it's interesting that this season is putting
people it i i guess it's sho i don't know this
feels like kind of a random thread so so bear
with me but i feel like this season is also
showing just how easy it is for altercations to
stir up and for people to escalate things because
especially amanda has been you know more of the
pacifist of the show and even she winds up in
a position that's very relatable to everybody
else so i feel like that then in combination
with uh the whole info dump about like no no
no you don't understand what terry silver did to
daniel like those two things together uh while you
could say like wow it's perfect timing that you
went on this trip and got in a fight but at the
same time i think they're good at tying together
those like convenient timeline things to make it
work within the magic of the show and uh yeah i
love the whole conflict resolution arc and that
they committed to that like at first i was like
i don't know i don't know exactly i guess this is
more for johnny uh but to have that one two three
of like okay let's sit down and talk okay that
doesn't work all right let's uh change the focus
and still work together okay you know what in
i thought it was interesting that in a show that
clearly isn't trying to promote the cobra kai
lifestyle is a show that's not trying to go like
fight all your problems physically i think it is
interesting to at least admit that like hey
for certain people and in certain situations
maybe that is the simplest answer and while that's
you know surely problematic especially for an
adult to supervise two kids beating each other
up at the same time i don't know philosophically
i'm like that is an interesting point because they
might not have gotten there any other way because
this is a language they both understand and they
both are very immersed in uh so yeah i don't know
i just continue to enjoy the geography of all
the different characters and uh you know we'll
see where stingray goes from here i was like where
is he where would terry silver just like put him
in a box i was about to mention at the end of this
episode if they didn't show him like are we gonna
get that payoff to what happened with stingray but
i answered it right away beginning of the episode
probably just hiding i'll just wait up here
until you feel this place don't play ps5
and i think we also established terry silver
doesn't really have that much money couldn't
even afford to get him a ps5 like broke ass
[__] yeah dude that's the tell right there
um even i got ps5 [__] terry silver terry silver
if you're watching i'll i'll take a piece yeah i
think with this episode it was so much about um
you know uh learning empathy by stepping in each
other's shoes you know like like you pointed
out with the role reversal of johnny and danny
and um and then of course with like amanda having
the bar situation and then i have a surprise
that she didn't hear the uh in-depth story of the
history of terry silver she never heard it before
yeah i was like it took your cousin telling you
this i thought danny would have surely have told
you what happened at one point yeah that would
be the most convincing way to sway you to his
arc because you didn't seem to you didn't seem to
really tell that much more than what i imagined
daddy could have outlined for you at some point
in this timeline um because you know i'm like
yeah it's really effective when you're seeing
flashbacks and stuff but amanda's not seeing the
flashbacks we are so i don't to me i don't know
to me i was like i really thought daniel would
have told you all this by this certain point and
uh yeah just getting to have different experiences
and understanding something i think the show does
really well which is showing you the opposite
sides or showing you the gray sides of things even
with like samantha coming in to defend her mom in
that bar fight bringing that out of her reminding
her of the good of karate that in this real life
world which is the world cobra kai really hones in
on is that there's always going to be [__] and
bullies and if you know how to defend yourself
that's not such a bad thing actually it's just
that sometimes within even the ones who learn
to defend breeds more bullying in some way so uh
yeah i thought like the thematically what they did
was awesome and i i just i feel like every episode
has kind of made me like cry a little bit yeah so
far definitely it was really i was really moved by
everything with robbie and johnny uh robbie and
miguel uh like their fight was really good i like
i think like those two actors have definitely
been training and uh it shows in their fight
choreography but again you know like you're really
all about terry i've been so much about miguel i'm
a cobra kind man you're all over the place robbie
yeah i've obviously i love all the characters
uh when it like miguel when he had the chance
to pretty much get his revenge and and knock
robbie over the railing like that was getting me
emotional of just like man all that all that like
anguish because this guy is like so nice man but
he's got so much like anger and hurt underneath
that that demeanor he's constantly wearing because
he is a good kind-hearted kid at the end of the
day and so you know to see all that pain being
unleashed within him but then making the choice
to not go through with it i i thought it was just
so moving i agree i'm just something as simple
as i'm sitting at the table and being like yeah
you can come get me emotional right now like you
you can come here anytime you want robbie just
that sense of acceptance and connection and
familial love like that [__] really tugs
in my heart so i i thought it like there's
this this episode in particular did a
quite a mastery and i felt like what
they're doing with daniel made the most it
really clicked with me this episode after
losing everything and really becoming washed
up and five o'clock shadowed trying to make
threatening the stingray and watching how he's
uh yeah just giving so much into his anger but
then you know even kind of going against my own
point when it does complement the flashbacks
you're like you know yeah terry silver guy could
have left a real traumatic impression on that kid
really could have because he he lured him
in under very false pretenses like i could
i could be the one who's your best friend and
help you and show you a new way but it was really
like you put all your trust into someone
to find out it was all just this one big
lie to crumble you um yeah that that would
be just very devastating so suddenly knowing
how like triggered he is because it can seem
like danny just kind of has a new replacement
villain every time which is just
villains from the original trolls
it can seem like he has a new
villain replacement every time
um you know from johnny to crease because you're
like well i feel like crease would be really
but crease was the difference with them is they
were always dicks you know whereas terry like
messed with your heart yeah and so that actually
put it into a much better perspective for me of
like oh yeah this makes a lot of sense why this is
like really ruining him um and it's something that
i didn't even consider of how much that negative
effect would be even stronger than someone like a
crease or a johnny because john was kind of like a
burden and then and chris was like the head honcho
of like the bad face that he always knew of
but terry was a very specific case and to
actually use what's the character's name jessica
jessica andrews yeah she was like a detective
yeah she was in karate kid part three she was
crying kid three right not karate kid the next
guarded kid with the hilary swank that was chosen
the bad guy in that movie was michael ironside
yeah it was like from an actual tv show and then
tarantino stapled it on to kill [__] that's a
field song kill bill compose for kill bill yeah
i just want to know one thing that wonderful
scene we got with robbie and miguel where you know
miguel made that you know that mature choice and
then they had that reaction when johnny
said uh that they were having a baby and
we thought you know it was going to be more of
a generic reaction where they were going to get
like what you're having a baby and then he
subverted our expectations i'm just really
curious did ryan johnson direct that scene or i
don't know no because if he did johnny would have
thrown the baby over his shirt that's true that's
true okay but the one question we want to know
greg is what did you think of the last jedi uh i i
find her very appreciated inside joke guys this so
far i think not to interrupt the ryan his trilogy
might still happen guys but uh i think so far this
season at least to my eyes has done a really nice
job of being a very satisfying and addictive binge
but i feel like each episode has been well-rounded
yeah and i feel like i could watch these spaced
out and still be like i'm loving this
you know yeah yeah definitely all right
enough out of all you guys running this
video now with a patron of the day shout out
kevin kev kevin my goodness you came here the
right time oh boy because we just looked up
your name on urban dictionary it's a doozy
a kevin especially a second generation kevin
is such a sweet and handsome man that everyone
wants to get to know clearly a kevin wrote this
he never fails to make you laugh you know every
kevin i've known has been mediocrely funny that's
all you need kevin is always there when you need
him and knows exactly what to say at the right
time usually the kevin's i know we usually have
a gap in communication and oftentimes i'm left
offended uh however yeah sometimes they're right
and no matter how stubborn you may be a kevin
knows how to bring you back down to earth usually
my craziest drug times were with kevin he is very
calm and level-headed definitely kind of fist
fights with him yeah kevin a kevin can talk to
you for hours and the conversation never gets old
usually i'm like yeah i've heard this story before
he is a very good listener kevin's are always
interrupted man what are we talking about
who who makes you see things in ways you would
never dream of seeing otherwise yeah like hatred
for kevin's kevin can be quite the head turner
but he is always loyal oh every kevin i've bad
business deals with everyone i've ever known
left and right he deeply cares about trust
and it can be extremely hard to earn it back once
it's gone i don't know about that a lot of nights
actually i don't know about that okay i won't
go there kevin love loves passionately and once
he has fallen for someone special he would do
anything and everything in his power to keep her
that's true i knew kevin once who chained a girl
and she wasn't going anywhere for years rotted uh
he always knows how to make you feel like the
most beautiful and special girl in the world
yeah i mean there's change is like the reward
very special there's no other woman's coming
in that room nobody else is going through
that there is never a dull moment with kevin
yeah oh man you know you go visit him in jail
and i'm telling you the stories that he has
wow you might get pulled into a brawl those
stories never get old that's for sure well kevin
you sound like a great guy so i'm happy to have
you here on our patreon page thanks for being here